okay so this is a mini episode which I
find confusing seeing how they're 11
minutes long this is two minutes
this is two minutes just three people to
talk about yes and it's called the wand
they find a wand and it's going crazy so
the Ice King helps to get rid of it and
it zaps the space and he looks weird the
end right like deep there's only two
things I could really think to say about
what is that it is interesting like the
design of Jake he does look different
because this came out like in the
earlier seasons and you know that the
mouth is served and a little smaller
even their chosen you know like the
mouth has got a little a little smaller
and that the whole face is again a touch
smaller compared the rest of the body
and the second thing is they really
shouldn't do these cuz I was stupid it
just seems like there's no reason to it
at all except like just a bonus feature
on the DVD and that's what it was it was
a bonus feature on the DVD well it shows
well why did you help us review that
there is nothing we can talk about with
it thank you a lot
tons of stuff again alright yeah be in
bed right now my goodness no not with
you though no no not with you sleeping
no key for one why is LSP in the wand
because she's awesome well after
watching the episode with her know she's
never that long
she's awesome in small doses yeah and it
was the perfect dose of her actually
yeah oh yeah it's terrible it's it's
that it's just pointless some point
listen we learned a lot like what we
learn okay that this is the first time
that we see well I'm guessing the wear
of the Ice King and Finn can team up and
actually work well together and the Ice
King isn't moron enough to here and
sacrifice yourself
the one rows and folds it nicely like
I'm gonna go sacrifice myself but I'm
holding my clothes hey I do like it's
like a grenade you keep I'd like to do
the V longer that's on well I thought it
was kind of neat how like all the things
were coming out of it and then what it
says about a roll out rubbing its tummy
it turns into something a lot more
sinister I mean the color do you can
tell this is definitely season one stuff
because the color of the monster it's
very kind of almost cutesy and like I
can see if it was done season like three
it could it would be like this dark
evil-looking color and it shows a good
contrast of how it used to be compared
to how it is now
yeah even sort of the line work looks a
touch different it looks a little
cleaner in the later seasons keep going
no see you just added something no you
okay but that's okay keep going so I can
add more or less I will take away from
your comment accepting of that George
you have anything to say
joy sit down Saddam Jory sit down it's
like what why what's she good I could be
sleeping right now let's just sleep and
have him hey guys it's Leah oh sweet Oh
check it out guys by the way Britt came
up with the screen IDs see and let my
fake gun Turk has you know Finn's
backpack and it actually fits perfectly
fine if you look right there there you
go let me go ahead Finn can go right
here oh look you're starting to smile
wolf is getting scared now Oh Andi oh my
god that is not even okay
what just happened